a million dollars a year breaks down to
83k per month 21k per week seven days
would be about 3k plus per day 21k per
week we just have to know what the
lifetime value of our customer is so
let's say you're selling a single
product that has no upsell let's say
your ltv is a thousand dollars just
means that your total lifetime value of
a customer is a thousand dollars like
starbucks i think they're ltv's like
eight thousand dollars and you're like
holy cow well think about how many times
you purchased a starbucks over the last
ten years if i sold a course for a
thousand dollars and i sold nothing else
that would be a thousand ltv if i sold a
hundred dollar a month gym membership
and the person on average stays 10
months that would be a thousand dollar
ltv skincare products average order
value was 250 and the average amount of
time that someone stayed on my cream
products was four months one thousand
dollars is my ltv if i have to get to a
million dollars then i need to sell 21
units per week and then there you go you
get your 10 million